bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24 nous
sommes à La Haye et notre invité
aujourd'hui et Charles Blé Goudé Charles
Blé Goudé bonjour monsieur vous êtes le
président du Congrès panafricain pour la
justice et l'égalité des peuples le
COGEP vous avez été ministre de la
Jeunesse sous Laurent Gbagbo vous avez
été acquitté par la Cour pénale
internationale de crime contre
l'humanité et il y a une dizaine de
jours le 30 mai exactement vous avez
reçu votre passeport ivoirien que vous
aviez déjà demandé il y a presque un an
ce passeport vous a été octroyé si je
puis dire directement par le Président
de la République à lassan Ouattara
merci
j'ai d'abord reçu une chef de cabinet du
président Alassane Ouattara ici le 5
avril dernier ensuite deux mois après
j'ai été appelé par
l'ambassadeur de la Côte d'Ivoire en
France donc notre ambassadeur qui venait
de recevoir le passeport demain du
directeur de cabinet du président
Ouattara je pense que tout cela est dû à
la situation de crise que traverse mon
pays donc on peut pas raisonner comme si
on était dans une situation normale je
ne justifie rien mais je pense que si je
suis resté ici et c'est parce que ma
situation devait certainement être
particulière et je vais pas le faire
d'histoire l'essentiel de passeport est
là et c'est après la mort du crapaud
qu'on voit sa longueur maintenant que le
passeport est là je pense qu'il faut
mettre tout cela derrière oui parce que
vous l'avez attendu vous l'avez réclamé
est-ce que vous avez douté de l'obtenir
non jamais d'abord parce que je sais que
j'y avais droit je savais que
cette attente là était dure aussi à la
situation de mon pays ce qui est la
prison m'a appris c'est la patience
en prison il faut attendre il faut
beaucoup attendre et c'est cela que j'ai
appris donc le passeport est là je vais
pas refaire l'histoire l'essentiel c'est
qu'il est là alors est-ce que cela
signifie comme c'est venu j'allais dire
presque directement des mains du
président Ouattara est-ce que ça veut
dire que il y a eu des discussions des
négociations un deal entre vous et lui
sur les conditions d'obtention de votre
passeport et donc de votre retour à
venir
aussi curieux que cela puisse paraître
le président ouattral m'a posé aucune
condition ni son chef de cabinet ni son
directeur de cabinet ni l'ambassadeur
ici qui va venir le passeport ce jour-là
non il y a pas eu de Didier
voilà ce que je voulais dire vous avez
dit plusieurs fois que votre objectif
votre ambition c'est d'être président de
la République de Côte d'Ivoire vous avez
été acquitté vous avez votre passeport
mais il y a aussi une condamnation à 20
ans de prison qui a été prononcé en 2019
contre vous pour meurtre viol torture
est-ce que vous craignez que cette
condamnation soit appliquée à votre
retour
avant moi beaucoup de leaders
de l'opposition ont été condamnés à 20
ans dont Laurent Gbagbo doit aussi Bendo
et bien d'autres ils sont retournés en
Côte d'Ivoire ils sont libres de leurs
mouvements je ne sais pas pourquoi et ma
situation serait différente vous êtes
cela dit je suis toujours en train de
parler avec les autorités de mon pays et
quand on veut mettre quelqu'un en prison
on lui envoie pas un chef de cabinet
cela demande tout de suite l'état
d'esprit et la vision que le chef de
l'État a dépassé tout ce qui s'est passé
en Côte d'Ivoire Nani mettant la manière
moi j'attends que mon tout arrive pour
qu'on en parle vous avez donc obtenu des
garanties que pas pour le moment on nous
sommes en discussion mais déjà vous
savez que
dès les premiers pas d'un poussin on
sera s'il devait un coq ou pas moi
j'observe simplement que le chef de
l'État est dans des bonnes dispositions
pour que on ne puisse pas retourner dans
une situation conflictuelle
évidemment la question se pose
maintenant de votre retour vous allez
donc le droit de façon officielle
administrative de rentrer en Côte
d'Ivoire quand est-ce que vous allez
rentrer Charles Blé Goudé
j'ai quitté la Côte d'Ivoire se font des
crises comme je l'ai déjà dit je vais
rentrer sous forme de paix je veux un
retour concerté avec les autorités de
mon pays c'est vrai donc des discussions
sur votre retour en ce moment même tout
à fait et parce que ce passeport me
permet tout de suite d'acheter un billet
d'avion et d'aller en Côte d'Ivoire j'ai
pas besoin de visa mais à quoi ça sert
tout cela je pense que nous avons
commencé une discussion que nous devons
terminer je suis en contact direct avec
le chef des cabinets de président de la
République pour que nous créons les
conditions de retour apaiser et notre
pays en a besoin voilà Charles Blé Goudé
mais pas forcément 11 pour les autres
démons même il faut discuter de tout
cela
je pense que on y est presque on y est
prête c'est quoi d'ici quelques semaines
vous serez à Abidjan vous serez informé
dès que nous avons une date mais c'est
une question de semaine pas de moi on
est d'accord
vous savez quand on a fait 11 ans hors
de son pays
et qu'on a attendu un an pour avoir un
passeport
pour retourner dans un pays qu'on a
quitté il y a 11 ans il y a des
dispositions à prendre et je pense qu'il
faut pas tout de suite si j'étais dans
la précipitation je vais parler avec les
autres études de mon pays je leur
proposer une ou deux dates et nous
allons discuter pour pouvoir arrêter un
agenda commun quand vous arrivez vous
allez voir le président Ouattara
quand on arrive dans un village il faut
aller voir le chef de village c'est une
tradition africaine je vais demander à
avoir le président Ouattara même avant
que je ne parle c'est formuler ma
demande audience c'est le minimum est-ce
que vous seriez prêt éventuellement à
travailler avec lui pour lui
on travaille toujours pour la Côte
d'Ivoire et non pour une personne c'est
son président vous pourriez peut-être je
sais pas devenir ministre ou c'est
totalement exclu on en est pas encore là
j'attends aussi beaucoup de bruit comme
ça des gens le Goudé va rentrer la
gouvernement du président Ouattara vous
pourriez me dire non c'est un ennemi
politique déjà nous sommes 26 millions
d'Ivoiriens et beaucoup de jeunes de mon
âge si déjà à chaque fois tu dois avoir
une gouvernement qu'on doit former des
gens me donner un destin ministériel je
vais pas bouder cela mais seulement
pour moi l'opposant doit être dans ce
registre d'opposant qui critique qui
propose et puis le gouvernement est
gouverne il faut que nous apprenons cela
les positions
variable à tout moment selon les petits
intérêts du moment c'est cela qui est le
mal de l'Afrique
on peut aider son pays sans forcément
être ministre moi je veux marcher droit
je vais marcher correct alors
vous avez passé des années en détention
juste à côté d'ici
avec Laurent Gbagbo vous allez souvent
dit que c'était votre père lui est
rentré maintenant que vous allez pouvoir
le faire mais il y a une chose que vous
n'avez pas fait c'est adhérer à son
nouveau parti le ppaci qu'il a lancé il
y a quelques mois tout d'abord est-ce
que il vous l'a proposé
non jamais ni directement ni directement
d'ailleurs je n'ai jamais été membre de
l'Ensemble lui-même comment pourrais-je
être membre d'un sous-ensemble
le PPCI sort du ventre du FPI
duquel je n'ai jamais été membre donc
n'ayant jamais été membre de l'ensemble
je me vois pas membre des sous-ensembles
et le président Laurent Gbagbo s'il ne
m'a pas proposé cela c'est parmi tous
ceux qui l'entourent c'est seul me
connaît réellement il sait que je suis
un homme libre on a toujours fonctionné
en Allier lui président fondateur du FPI
moi président du projet et puis en son
temps c'était général la fessée ça n'a
jamais dérangé ma liberté on peut ne pas
parler d'une même voix ou d'une seule
voix et on peut parler d'une même voix
ce qui compte ce sont les problèmes des
Ivoiriens ce n'est pas la voix unique
qui compte est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que vous n'étiez pas le
bienvenu dans son parti pas forcément de
la part de Laurent Gbagbo mais peut-être
de gens autour de lui oui son entourage
a travaillé pendant plusieurs années
avant hostile
l'environnement autour de Laurent Gbagbo
hostile à ma personne et d'ailleurs je
ne sais pas pourquoi il y a tout ce
débat autour de mes rapports avec
Laurent Gbagbo alors on va parler de vos
rapports avec Simone Gbagbo Simone Bagbo
on le sait à divorcé avec Laurent Gbagbo
mais il y a aussi un divorce politique
qui est en train de prendre forme elle
va lancer sa formation politique vous
avez souvent exprimé votre admiration
pour elle est-ce que vous pourriez
joindre vos forces celle du COGEP à
celle de Simone Gbagbo
d'abord
je voudrais dire que tous ces divorces
dont vous parlez
concernent deux personnes
ce n'est pas un référendum
c'est un contraste dans la gamme entre
deux personnes deux individus
moi
que je puisse dire au moment où je vous
parle sinon Gbagbo n'a posé aucun acte
qui puisse m'amener à remettre en cause
l'admiration que j'ai pour elle je
l'admire toujours et elle me fascine de
plus en plus elle a une capacité de
résilience qui peut faire quatre écoles
donc elle pourrait être une alliée
politique peut-être plus que Laurent
Gbagbo à l'avenir d'abord nous avons les
mêmes valeurs
[Musique]
nous sommes tous deux de gauche
elle s'intéresse à mon quotidien
et c'est une mère en plus d'être leader
vous parlez régulièrement nous parlons
régulièrement et je pense que tout cela
n'est pas exclu tout comme d'autres
hommes de gauche qui ont des formations
politiques rien exclut que nous
puissions nous organiser demain
la limitation d'âge en Côte d'Ivoire on
en parle il y a un nouveau projet de loi
pour la remettre une limitation à 75 ans
qui de facto élimineraient à la sanatara
Laurent Gbagbo Henri konombédier de la
prochaine élection prévue en 2025 on
sait que c'était une mesure qui était en
place est-ce que vous vous êtes
favorable à cette limitation d'âge parce
que peut-être que ça peut arranger vos
propres ambitions non pas sous cet angle
là parce que une loi doit être
impersonnelle vous avez cité trois
individus nous sommes 26 millions
d'individus en Côte d'Ivoire mais cela
peut impersonnel et cette limitation
d'âge était déjà introduite dans notre
Constitution avant que hier cette
modification de la Constitution j'étais
d'accord avec nous étions tous d'accord
avec et moi mes positions ne varient pas
selon mes petits intérêts j'étais
d'accord avec la limitation d'Allah je
suis d'accord avec l'administration
d'argent aujourd'hui c'est clair la
limite
la limitation du nombre de mandats
présidentielles on sait que Alassane
Ouattara c'est présenté un nouveau
mandat peut-être contraint et forcé mais
ça a fait débat ça fait des banques
d'Ivoire dans de nombreux pays parce que
les règles sont toujours floues ou
contournées et au final la démocratie
semble en souffrir en Afrique
la limitation des mandats c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'alternance
et ça met le président en exercice dans
une position de savoir que d'un moment
l'autre quand son mandat finit un jour
ou l'autre il peut se retrouver parmi
les citoyens ordinaires ce qui lui
permet de faire attention aux lois qu'il
prend c'est qu'il permet de faire
attention à sa gouvernance je pense que
l'Afrique devait encourager cela
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas moi
je milite pour l'alimentation de demande
Alassane Ouattara ne l'a pas respecté
oui mais ce n'est pas de cela qu'il
s'agit ici je ne veux pas commenter
c'est que Alassane Ouattara a fait ce
que je dis aujourd'hui c'est que je suis
pour l'alimentation d'âge et je souhaite
qu'en Afrique notre leader les
différents présidents puissent au moins
respecter la limitation de grâce ce qui
va éviter c'est pour d'État qui en a
pour infini vous avez souvent dit que
vous voulez être président de la
République est-ce que vous serez
candidat en 2025 la prochaine élection
prévue
nous sommes en 2022 j'ai fait 11 ans
hors de mon pays j'ai entendu un
passeport pendant un an il vient
d'arriver permettez que je puisse
arriver en Côte d'Ivoire pour pouvoir
discuter avec les miens et prendre le
pouls de la situation en Côte d'Ivoire
parce que voyez-vous monsieur pédalement
une élection présidentielle c'est pas
une élection des chefs de village voilà
une leçon présidentielle est un
rendez-vous entre une personnalité et un
peuple mais aussi un contexte que sera
le contexte au moment où j'arrive la
Côte d'Ivoire changer derrière moi je
pense que ce n'est pas une décision qui
m'appartait moi seul j'ai une équipe
j'ai un parti j'ai des alliés j'ai des
amis que je vais rencontrer des
ambitions toujours et mes ambitions ne
sont pas au-dessus de la situation de
mon pays ce n'est qu'une ambition
Charles Blé Goudé merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu aux questions de France 24
depuis La Haye merci à vous d'avoir
suivi cet entretien rester sur nos
antennes pour plus d'informations
[Musique]